reasontv presents citizens against
government waste porker of the month
Ohio representative Marcy Kaptur back
they were trying to comply with the new
rules say you're a 14 term congresswoman
who is just narrowly cleared of ethics
violations for delivering earmarks in
exchange for campaign contributions
maybe to clear up your image you and
your colleagues in the House
Appropriations Committee ban the process
of awarding ear march to for-profit
companies but those for-profit companies
were some of your biggest campaign
contributors surely there must be a way
to funnel more taxpayer money to your
friends so you direct them to create a
non-profit shell corporation that not
only does the same work but has the same
staff and even the same address as the
original company now they can receive
all the earmark requests you can muster
maybe 5.2 million dollars to demonstrate
the ability to produce small hollow
spheres of metal alloys that takes balls
of steel you notified any company if you
want to apply you have to come in as a
not-for-profit and according to the New
York Times captor is just one of many in
the house already circumventing their
new earmark accountability rules for
more information on poker of the month
and other government waste issues visit
CA GW org